foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so Canada
I feel like a lot of times maybe they
don't really get the attention or the
respect that they deserve in regards to
their contributions to the horror genre
let's say that I mean Canada has given
us I mean when you really think about it
uh one of the earliest as well as one of
still one of the best slasher films
which of course was Black Christmas from
1974. uh one of the best werewolf movies
which was Ginger Snaps one of the best
ghost stories slash Haunted House movies
which was the changeling
um and the entire catalog of David God
damn Cronenberg as well as Brandon
Cronenberg his son who is also like
makes some great movies in his own right
but despite all of that
it kind of seems like a lot of horror
movies that come out of Canada they
either tend to fly under the radar or if
they get some kind of like mainstream
success I feel like a lot of people just
sort of like forget that they're
Canadian and just kind of like lump them
in with American movies maybe that's not
the case but that was like always the
impression that I got now the slasher
sub genre though
is you know fairly well represented uh
by some you know very standout Canadian
films obviously uh there's prom night
which is very popular and the
aforementioned black Christmas which
need I have to remind you actually came
out four years before John Carpenter's
Halloween uh and kind of set the
template for Holiday slashers I guess
like going forward but we also got some
underrated slasher films like My Bloody
Valentine from 1981 uh Happy Birthday to
me which is great I really need to
review that uh one of these days now I
don't think about it and uh visiting
hours which is another one that a lot of
people don't uh talk about and then
we have the weird kind of hybrid movie
that we're talking about today which is
1983's slasher psychodrama curtains
now this was directed sort of I'll get
into this in a minute by a guy named
Richard chupka I think is how you
pronounce his last name I'm not entirely
sure uh so I apologize but this movie
had a notoriously like troubled
production that in a lot of ways is just
as interesting as the film itself
so the concept behind curtains it was
actually hatched back in 1980
after the producer whose name was Peter
R Simpson he had had success with prom
night he was the producer on that as
well and he was looking to cash in with
another slasher film but he wanted one
like he wanted like a slightly different
take on it you know what I mean so he
brings on the writer Robert guza Jr who
had actually co-written prom night with
William Gray and what Simpson wanted to
do was that he didn't really want to go
the same because you know the movie
terror train which was also kind of like
a slasher and more like a teen I guess
it was like a teen young adult kind of
slasher that had come out and he wanted
to avoid doing another like teen slasher
type of thing so he wanted something
aimed toward maybe like a more adult
audience now that's not to say that he
didn't want something commercially
viable like he still wanted it to be
essentially like a traditional slasher
movie Just is one that would appeal to
an older crowd that maybe like had some
older characters and wasn't just like
set at a school or had a bunch of
teenagers or college students or
whatever
now the director Richard chipka
seemingly wanted the same thing
but
um clashes soon ensued let's call it
that uh over his personal vision of the
film which was actually less slasher
movie and more like Arty Thriller type
of thing that's what he wanted to do
so they started having like these
horrible conflicts on set about their
conflicting visions of like what they
wanted the movie to be and eventually
after really shooting only about 45
minutes worth of usable footage uh
Richard chupka quit and Simpson the
producer he took over the director's
chair now shipka in fact was so incensed
by this whole [ __ ] show that he actually
asked for his name to be taken off the
movie when it was eventually released uh
you know several years later uh so the
director of curtains if you still watch
it to this day is credited as Jonathan
Striker which is actually the name of
the fictional director character that's
in the movie so this conflict uh you
know probably not surprisingly I guess
between these two differing ideas behind
what curtains was supposed to be kind of
left its fingerprints all over the final
product
um as did the the fact that this thing
was essentially like filmed in fits and
starts like over almost like a three
year period like some of it was filmed
it was put on a shelf for a year they
had to like call people back stuff was
recast they did like numerous rewrites
and reshoots and reboots and it was just
like like I said it was a complete and
total [ __ ] show now given the shambolic
nature of its creation it's actually
pretty amazing that curtains is as
coherent and is relatively enjoyable as
it is now don't get me wrong I'm not
like you know totally blown smoke and
say this is you know a lost classic or
anything like that but it's pretty
decent and I mean if you're in the mood
for kind of like a slow burn
psychological Thriller that's kind of
set in this like backstabbing uh you
know kind of framework of uh you know
actors actresses casting couch that kind
of stuff and that also has some mild
slasher elements to it then you might
just get a kick out of it so the story
of curtains uh centers around a famous
and somewhat kind of imperious actor
named Samantha Sherwood now she's played
by Samantha Edgar who's probably best
known to horror fans for her amazing
turn in David cronenberg's The Brood
um Edgar by the way has gone on record
as saying that she absolutely hates this
movie and really only did it for the
paycheck but to be honest I think she's
kind of like selling herself as well as
the film short because she's pretty
[ __ ] great in this so Samantha is
actually the collaborator slash Muse
type person for director Jonathan
Striker who's actually played by John
Vernon who was in a ton of [ __ ] he was
in Animal House he was in Dirty Harry he
was in uh killer clowns from outer space
which probably were a lot of horror fans
know him from uh actually this part fun
fact was originally written for Klaus
which would have made this a lot
different film that's all I'm saying
um so yeah so Jonathan Striker this
director uh he's working on a movie
called Audra as a vehicle for his
favorite leading lady who is Samantha
now because the title character of the
movie Audra is like a mad woman Samantha
who is like very method she's a method
actor so she opted to have herself
committed to a mental hospital
um for real so she can kind of really
get a handle on the role however
unfortunately for her Striker is a total
douche canoe who seemingly from the
beginning really had no intention of
having Samantha Star in this movie and
he basically just like leaves her ass in
the asylum
while he goes and picks out six younger
women to travel to this kind of remote
country house for a prolonged like
audition session I think it's going to
take place like over one weekend or
something like that now it will probably
surprise no one in these uh post
Weinstein days uh that this audition
session is also going to involve him
seducing some or all of the ladies
because you know of course it does now
we see early on in the film that the
very resourceful Samantha has actually
escaped from the mental hospital with
the help of a friend of hers and she
very openly like Val's revenge on
Striker as well as the beautiful
actresses that are all kind of gunning
to take her place in this movie in this
role that she you know had pretty much
like said was hers
so this whole First Act plays out as
though it's setting up like an
understandable motive for Samantha who
we're led to believe is going to end up
being the killer but the movie actually
has kind of some twists up its sleeve in
that regard now out of the six women
summoned to this audition
um one of them actually never even makes
it there there's a woman named Amanda
who's played by Deborah Burgess and she
has this really bizarre dream in which
she's driving to the audition but she
sees this real creepy doll like just
kind of like sitting in the middle of
the road and you know like you shouldn't
do in a horror movie she gets out of the
car to like check it out and
subsequently like somebody climbs into
her car and like runs her over
essentially but like I said this is a
dream sequence they don't really make
any um you know they well they do kind
of like fake you out on that but yes
it's a dream sequence she wakes up and
kind of like shakes it off she's like ah
that was weird
um she then and there's then kind of
another fake out where you think
somebody is broken into a apartment is
like raping her but then it turns out
that it's just her boyfriend and they're
doing like some weird like rape fantasy
role play so I'm like okay there's a lot
of like fake out kind of stuff not jump
scares necessarily but like fake out
kind of things like that but then she
does actually later get murdered for
Real by a killer who's wearing like
actually like a pretty scary hag mask I
will say that like the mask that the
killer wears in this is one of the best
like slasher movie masks like in all of
slasher medium it's really really creepy
so the killer actually takes Amanda's
creepy doll like the same one that was
in her dream which is like I don't know
why anybody would make or want a doll
like this it's just like really like it
has this really like creepy like sad
frowny face it's like yeah it's really
disquieting so yeah so the killer takes
that doll and presumably makes their way
to the house where all of the auditions
are going to be taking place so the five
remaining candidates for the role they
arrive for their shot at stardom under
the sleazy ministrations of Jonathan
Striker the director so the characters
we have uh the comedian who's named
Patty she's actually played by Lynn
Griffin who is in Black Christmas she
was actually the first one I think that
got taken out the one with the bag in
the closet that was sitting up in the uh
you know in the Attic the whole time
that's her
um you also have one who's a dancer his
name is Lorien and you have one who's
like a musician I think um named Tara
and then you have this kind of like
she's an ice skater but she's kind of
like this naive like Goody Two-Shoes
type of girl and her name's Christy
she's actually played by Leslie donnison
Donaldson who was also in happy birthday
to me like another Canadian slasher and
then you have kind of the veteran actor
that's like a little bit older a little
more famous than the other ones and her
name is Brooke and she's actually played
by Linda Thorson who I think was like
best known for being on the she was kind
of I think she played that character
Tara King like on the last season of The
Avengers like that British TV show
um so already at the house when they get
there is like this dude that's like a
caretaker I guess like kind of he's kind
of like a young guy and his name is
Matthew and he's actually played by
Michael wincott who was actually in the
crow and strange days he was in a lot of
things
um and he actually wastes no time at all
and like jumping into the hot tub with
Tara And you know the two of them get
down to business so while everybody at
the house like sits down to dinner
getting acquainted and like talking
about the shameful and sometimes illegal
things that they're willing to do like
to get this part who should show up
unexpectedly but Samantha Who sachets
right into the dining room like she owns
the place and calls Striker out for his
basically treachery and like leaving her
in the mental Asylum Striker is
obviously uh furious at this but he kind
of manages to keep his temper in check
until later when he kind of like lets
Samantha have it in private now their
screeching argument is actually
overheard by Christy like the naive ice
skater girl but Striker says like when
he opens the door and sees her there
he's like oh well we were just like
rehearsing this play it's like this it's
not real what we were talking about now
after Christy goes to her room uh
Striker actually like slimes his way in
and has sex with her
um undoubtedly telling her that she's
gonna have to [ __ ] if she wants to roll
bad enough because she looks like like
after he leaves she's like crying like
she feels like [ __ ] about herself you
know what I mean now the next morning
Christy gets up real early and goes out
to practice her skating routine like
presumably she does every morning
um because there's like kind of a frozen
lake nearby there's ice but in what is
actually the film's best sequence and
the one that everybody talks about when
they talk about this movie
um she kind of like she's skating and
then she she gets kind of like unsettled
after her music shuts off and she goes
over there to see what the problem is
and she notices like a doll's hand like
poking out of the snow like near her
boom box so she digs the creepy doll
like out of the snow
um and of course it's the same creepy
doll from Amanda's dream earlier and
then Christy turn turns around to see
the figure like in the hag mask like
skating toward her in like slow motion
it's really great because it's really
like the like I said the mask is really
creepy and the slow motion sometimes
that can be cheesy but like in this case
I think it came across with like almost
like dreamlike or surreal and I think
that makes it like way way creepier
so the killer like has this uh has a
sickle which you actually saw them
sharpening like earlier on now Christy
is actually able to fight off the killer
momentarily and she kind of flees into
the woods but the person in the hag mask
like ultimately catches up with her and
like slices off her head now this
particular scene as I mentioned has
appeared on several scariest horror
movie scenes lists and I think
deservedly so um it's really really ear
it's not super graphic or anything like
that but it's really really eerie like
the way that it's shot and I will say
that although the rest of the movie like
surrounding it isn't as striking or as
effective as that one scene is it's
pretty I mean it's a pretty great bit
like while it lasts so as the story goes
on in true uh you know slasher movie
fashion the victims start to get picked
off one by one by this masked killer
um although I will say and I think I
alluded to this earlier like unlike some
other slasher movies from this era The
Kills are pretty tame and a lot of them
are like pretty bloodless like there's a
little bit of nudity but this isn't one
of those kind of like you know
gratuitous violence or gratuitous nudity
kind of things matter of fact Matthew
like the guy that's the caretaker at the
house he actually gets murdered off
screen
um his death scene was apparently filmed
like as far as I could determine but it
for whatever reason it didn't make it
into the final cut so like I said some
of the people kind of get killed off
screen and they'll again get found later
on
um really the only somewhat gory event
that happens in the movie is the finding
of Christy's head like in the toilet in
Brooke's bathroom and even that is not
terribly terribly graphic because it's
kind of like she sees it in there she
freaks out she goes and tells Striker
about it and he's like it's just your
imagination come here I'll show you and
then they go back and then there's no
head in there anymore so it's like I
said they cut it kind of has a weird
like dream like it doesn't make a lot of
sense like if you think too hard about
it it's almost like it gives like a
little bit of a giallo kind of vibe in
that way
so you can't like think too hard about
plot you know things in the plot and
stuff like that because a lot of times
you'd be like wait what but you know
what I mean just don't think about it
too hard so I'm just saying two like
don't expect a great deal of like real
gruesome slashing in this movie because
I would call this maybe like a
quasi-slasher type of thing
um I think you'll definitely be
disappointed if you're looking for like
something that's super gruesome or super
over the top or graphic because this is
definitely not bad so at last toward the
end the character count is down to the
final two and while we've been primed
through the entire movie to suspect that
Samantha is obviously the killer uh the
truth actually ends up being slightly
more complicated than that now I'll
admit that I didn't entirely see the
reveal coming I will note that I was
expecting a Twist because I didn't think
they would set up Samantha so obviously
as the culprit and then have her you
know actually be the culprit like all
along so the ending wasn't completely
unexpected but it also wasn't totally
expected either like if that makes any
sense now I will say I mean curtains
isn't a traditional slasher
um in that way so it will probably just
frustrate
um fans who were kind of looking for
your typical like body count blood bath
type of slasher movie but that said
there is some good stuff in here that
makes it worth a watch like if you're in
the right frame of mind I mean I will
say the pacing is a little bit uneven
and a little bit sluggish at times like
I said some plot points don't make a lot
of sense if you think about them too
hard
um it often seems to lean much more in
the direction of like a drama or a
Revenge Thriller than a straight horror
movie or a straight slasher movie but it
does have some like pretty effective
like chilling sequences such as the
previously mentioned like ice skating
kill which is probably the most famous
one and also like the final chase scene
with one of the characters kind of being
pursued through this kind of creepy prop
shed that was actually like pretty good
too
um the acting in this too gotta say is
also way way better than many of the
other slashers of the era and that kind
of like elevates it it gives it like a
little bit of Like A Touch of Class that
you don't usually see like in your
standard like cheap schlocky like 80s
slasher type movies
um and honestly besides that the hag
mask that the killer wears is really
original and is actually like really
genuinely frightening and creepy and the
doll that turns up here and there is
actually like pretty Eerie too although
I will say that they I wish they had
done more with the doll like
Incorporated the doll like more into the
story because it is like on the poster
and everything like that and it was like
a really creepy aspect that I kind of
wish that they had Incorporated more
into the story but you know what are you
gonna do
um you know so all in all it's not like
a magnificent film or anything like that
but it's like pretty interesting
nonetheless especially if you like
slashers but something like a little bit
different and like I said it almost has
a slight Vibe of more like a giallo type
of movie too so I mean I'd recommend it
if you're into like Canadian horror or
if you like slashers but you don't
really care if it's like super graphic
or anything and you just want to see
like a different take on it that's more
adult oriented I guess just in the sense
of like the characters being older and
stuff but yeah it's definitely worth
watching so if you've seen it let me
know what you thought about in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear I'll see you guys again
on the next one bye